foreign
[Music]
hello everyone my name is
my name is I'm a 50-year PhD student at
Columbia and I'm also a Simon's fellow
for the semester today I'm going to talk
about faster investment and data
structure for faster iconic programming
problems and I should mention if you are
interested in my talk today please also
check out the videos of a lecture that I
gave last week in the boot camp about
Matrix data structures where I will
cover a lot of the stuff that I talk
about today in more details
okay so let me first start from a bigger
picture about this recent progress on
trying to use better data structures to
achieve faster optimization algorithms
so many algorithms for organization
problems are iterative in nature for
example gradient descent or taking
mutant steps and all these algorithms
high level Lee you can always measure
their time as the number of iterations
times the cost per iteration so when
designing these algorithms there are
always two themes the first one is to
reduce the number of iterations and
there has been extensive studies on that
and the second part is what I will focus
on today which is to reduce the cost per
iteration and the idea behind this is
that many iterative measures are very
robust inherently
so instead of computing the variables
from scratch in generation which can be
very expensive
we can use data structures to implicitly
maintain some solution and only do a
smaller update each generation
and sort of what I will talk about today
is about my research which is focused on
using inverse maintenance data structure
for the type of algorithms that's
interior Point methods and for chronic
programming so next let me Define these
three definitions here and then I will
give you some list about recent progress
about other people's work and my work as
well
okay so let's start with the definition
of chronic programming
so in Connect programming what we wanted
to do is we wanted to optimize some
linear objective subject to some linear
constraints and with the extra heart
constraint which is the variables should
be in some convex column the simplest
and most well-known example is linear
programming that Bento just talked about
where in this example our coincident
negative Orson as shown in the figure
here but there are also other examples
another very widely used example is
semi-definite programming where in this
example the cone is the cone of positive
summative matrices and you can see the
cone here on in the figure on the right
where this is the column of PSD matrices
that have size 2x2 and there are also
other examples another example I will
cover today is sum of squares
optimization where in this problem the
co is the set of polynomials that can be
written as a sum of squares and there
are also other examples okay now we've
talked about chronic programming let's
move on to the other two definitions
that I have in the first slide which are
inverse maintenance and interior Point
methods so one of the most widely used
algorithm for conic programming is
called interior Point method this method
is not only fast in theory but it's also
very fast in practice so it's
implemented in many solvers and high
level lead what does it do is that this
is an iterative algorithm that moves in
the interior of the feasible region and
gradually moves towards the optimal
solution
and each step of the IPM can be viewed
as a Newton step so you can view it as
hashing errors times the gradient and
now you see why where the inverse shows
up
and the observation is that in IPM the
Hessian is usually changing pretty
slowly so we can use a inverse
maintenance data structure that only
perform some update to your inverse and
maintain this inverse during different
iterations so this data structure will
support two operations the first one is
an update operation where we only change
a figure entries of the Matrix itself
and the second operation is a query
operation that will output The Matrix
Vector product of the inverse of hashing
times some vector
and we can design better data structures
and then by using a better trade-off
between the update and query this will
improve the cost per iteration and I
should mention this is a very old idea
that dates back to the original
paperback.com marker in 1984 and Bible
idea in 1989 but there has been recent
new interest in this big framework and
there has been more complicated
amortization scheme and better data
structures that gives Improvement okay
so next I will talk about some recent
developments starting from LP so for LP
the formulation that we consider the
general formulation that I talked about
about conic programming would become
this formulation here where the
constraint is just that the acts are all
an end all and then zero sorry are
non-negative and then we have some
constrained Matrix here a which have
size d by n so there are usually two
cases that we consider for LP the first
one is the square case where you have
about the same number of constraints as
the number of variables and the second
one is the flat case where the number of
constraints is much smaller than the
number of variables
okay and then we start from some old
paper by value that I've mentioned on
the previous slide as well uh where he
showed that oh okay another thing I
should mention all the results that I
cover in this slide on the next slide
will just ignore the bit dependence
because they will all have this out
dependence and he'll just talk about so
they all fall into the other category
that he said yeah okay so let me start
with this paper by Maria where he showed
that they can by using this slowly
changing framework you can get driven
iterations is standard but you can get a
squared cost per iteration where if you
compute the hash and inverse naively it
would take a cube if you're in practice
or until the Omega where Omega is the
fast measures multiplication time if you
are in theory okay and then there has
been recent work on both two slides let
me just quickly mention on the side of
reducing the number of iterations
there's a seminal paper by Leanne
sedford which get routine iterations and
they use a different barrier function so
they change the IPM itself and on the
side of reduce the cost per iteration
all the recent work sort of follows I'm
trying to answer this broad question can
we solve linear programs in the optimal
time but what does US mean by Optimal
time well number one in order to solve
an LP you need to solve some linear
constraints so as a lower bound it's the
time of solving linear equations and as
another lower bound is you have to read
your input Matrix so your input sparsity
would be the optical time and there has
been oh and for solving linear systems
for General dance Matrix we don't know
anything better but then just compute
the inverse itself which would take into
the Omega time where Omega is the matrix
multiplication exponent
and let me show some results here so for
the square case this paper by Cohan
lienzo in 2019 showed that uh for LP we
can recover the same running time as the
current matrix multiplication time where
they gave a runtime up into the Omega
plus and to the two and one over six and
the later Improvement by myself and
other collaborators show that we can
further improve this into the two and
one six to decrease it to enter 2 and 1
18. I talk about this in more details in
the lecture last week so you can check
out the video if you are interested and
then on the flat case flat LP case
um the current best running time runs in
order and D plus d to the 2.5 so if you
have your variable size is more than D
to the 1.5 then this already gives the
same running time as the input size
okay and you can see like there's let me
just quickly mention like a
straightforward open problem would be so
this is
the input sparse input size time when
your input Matrix is dense what if your
input Matrix is sparse is there any way
to exploit that I think that's unknown
right now
okay and second let me go through other
iconic programming which are at sdp and
SOS so for sdp our formulation would be
we still have the linear objective and a
bunch of linear constraints but now they
are with respect to the Matrix X because
our variable is the x that is a PSD
Matrix and in this case we usually say
there are M number of constraints and M
should be smaller than N squared because
otherwise you have more number of
constraints than your variables and some
of them become trivial
okay so it's a classic result for sdp is
by nasarov and namorovsky in 1992 where
for STP there's also a number of
iterations and their cost per iteration
is M squared N squared plus M times
Omega plus m to the Omega
um and then there has been research
recently uh follow about reducing the
cost per iteration for sdp uh so one
paper in
2020 showed that you can improve the
cost per iteration to MN squared plus
I'm Omega plus and Omega and a later
paper by myself and other collaborators
will show that in some regime we can
further improve upon this previous paper
so in the case where there are many
number of constraints that have roughly
the same order as the number of
variables we get a similar result as in
the lp case which would run in like uh
into the Omega time for the current
matrix multiplication exponent
and we can also use the same framework
to reduce the running time for sum of
squares organization as well okay so
finally let me end up with one very
specific open problem that I'm happy to
explore when I'm here which is can we
further improve the running time for STP
solvers because if you look at the
running time of the current to state of
the art LPS hours I don't think they are
tight right now so I think there's still
room of improvement
and another question would be can we get
a better iteration con for sdps hours as
well uh because for the lp solver as I
mentioned there was this recent paper
where it reduces the cost like the
number of iterations from root n to root
D and in some cases you can have much
fewer number of constraints than the
number of variables so it's unknown if
we can get something similar for sdp or
for other conic programming questions
okay so that is all thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
has there been work on bounding these
space requirements for solving these
things
uh
I don't think so but I also don't think
there used that much space I think it's
a space usage
I'm in the audience I think it's I'm
wondering if you can get
sub quadratic uh leaving aside the input
that's a good question but I have never
I don't think there's any work on that
not I'm aware of
because for example something I did long
ago with first order methods on uh
certain stps certain specific sdps you
can actually
uh do that and and actually use them in
the approximation algorithms for which
you're using LPS in in time linear so if
you have a matrix for example that's
sparse you might want to do it in space
that's uh number of non-zeros there are
work that exploit other structures but
there are spars that would have implied
that for example I think there are work
that exploit if your STP some graph
corresponds to the SCP have low Tribbles
I think it would it will have some like
linear linear running time
for those special spps is probably in
the same direction as what you're saying
sushant and I were just exchanging
glances I don't think we know how to
solve linear system sub quadratically
yeah basically space is there a
sub-swagenic space is there any hope of
solving linear systems uh in
sub quadratically
don't have a good story for Hope but I
haven't I mean I haven't thought about
it yeah anybody I don't want to take
away from the speaker
excellent discussion
any other questions
maybe I'll ask a question so so some of
these recent breakthroughs on Max flow
go by increasing the number of
iterations by doing something simpler is
there any
hope for doing that for richer classes
of lpes or
yeah I mean all of these were on Square
very interesting questions so we are
currently trying to remove the one over
18 and that's one idea we are trying to
exploit right now so yeah
any other questions
thank you again
[Music]
[Applause]